what's our goal here after we've tasted
10 taco trucks what are we gonna be able
to say are we finding the best taco
truck in LA I think we're looking for
the best taco truck experience also we
should probably have you established our
credentials no see I'm not an expert
you're definitely not an expert at a
taco expert in terms of authenticity I
am half Mexican though I wouldn't
consider myself a reputable verifier
about sake of authenticity I speak from
poquito I'm not trying to you know pee
on your guy's legs here and tell you
it's rain kind of thing I'm trying to be
as forthcoming and transparent as I can
on this transparent taco journey wait
can we add T to that tantalizing
transparent taco during its to many T's
trip the tantalizing taco trip
tantalizing transparent taco trip that's
four T's we just love tacos man that's
all I know so we're gonna do five trucks
today and in five trucks tomorrow ten
trucks told so that'll explain why we
change clothes in the middle of the
episode exactly got it first stop loss'
trailer tacos Australia Australia yeah
the Stars alright this is about 30
minutes away let's go
[Music]
can we get four tacos to a house door
the door into the sauna yeah yeah oh I
take cash okay which one you're going
first
I'm going for a sauna first all right
let's do it Oh ma'am I find a thought it
to be a lacking flavor sometimes this
has good flavor how's the tortilla for
you the tortilla is like standard I
wouldn't say it's like anything
spectacular but you know what when you
have meat that's this good you don't
really need to do anything too fancy
with the tortilla huh
no this is odd this passed door kind of
has the quality and texture of carnitas
can't think of another way to describe
it other than then shred it it's still
good but this definitely feels like it
was coming out of a crock pot is it
worth the drive no I don't think I'd
voyage over here just if I was craving
this but if this was in my neighborhood
I would come here all the time I would
definitely eat six of those I'm also a
pig should we get more tacos all right
from here yeah next place okay is about
say we got like four more trucks pay me
to get back on that train if you know
what I'm saying it's go what do we got
for a first stop two on the taco tour
here Ricky's fish tacos half a mile away
one minute's we've been here before so
if we can't find this that just means
we're bad navigators and not so much
commentary on the taco truck itself we
did almost run out of gas in Las Vegas
twice city second now we're going to
stop moving the shells there I'm gonna
close through the stop sign Oh weights
right here I can see it okay it's under
there preach my control throws are on
the bridge right now under no Charles
are under bridges huh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I'm gonna get the Ricky special as
I always do here look at that work of
art right there let's do it good
mouthfeel on this you have like the hot
crispy fish and shrimp but then you have
the fresh cold ingredients of cabbage
and you know tomatoes and peppers
it's the batter it is just perfect it's
crispy and crunchy and flaky but not
Whaley it almost tastes healthy because
it's so fresh the truck is just painted
with praise for itself you're just like
all right don't sprained a muscle
jerking yourself off and then you have
the taco now you're just like oh that's
a competent truck the only problem is
that these are expensive but one taco is
the amount of like three normal tacos at
any other truck I have a friend from out
of town who I showed this taco truck and
when she came back into town the first
thing she asked to do was to go to
Ricky's fish tacos again
that's how goddamn good at this last to
you Ricky is take that Grauman's Chinese
Theater Hollywood Walk of Fame
Ricky's fish tacos Top Billing if we can
make Ricky's fish tacos a number-one
tourist attraction in LA they would
actually be pretty light it may be
pretty upset because then there's beer
there'd be long lines oh that's true all
right no it's horrible nobody could
leave this footage delete this footage
this is God by Ricky's we love you is
the best
Ricky's is the best
[Music]
so we uh we went to the wrong truck yeah
there's two taco trucks both begin with
bed we're named mariscos and eat it
though why not let's try it
regarde I'm good
it's an oppa mushy there's a little
mushy I'm not gonna eat more I'm gonna
save my room for the real stuff real
thing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's fears it's so much better
there's a lot better news no offense to
your truck this is just better
crap I come out of Chris what's in the
center good it isn't much it's not just
shrimp in the middle I don't know it's
like a seafood medley around it
Nicole bhava kado in the cold sauce on
top of the piping hot fried shell is so
good how do you think they even make
that so what my Garant my grandma does
she takes the tortilla clamps it around
the meat and puts like toothpicks in it
and achieve deep fries it there's a bee
right by the knee
I would probably drive to get this just
because I don't know end of any sorry
oh that's killing me I think I would
drive to this truck just cuz I don't
know any other truck that serves tacos
this way well we know of one other truck
that serves fabulous life all right
let's get out of here get in wrecked
this is uh this is also a nice just
portrait into what it's like to drive
around in LA
just getting reamed daily by traffic
well thank you Brian for taking me all
the way down to Carson so I could see
the outside of a galaxy game and Tron
chose tacos which we can't get to unless
we purchase tickets to said galaxies
game glad this made the list so this is
Brent on the phone with John chose tacos
trying to see if they were less
conscious tacos right there so we drove
all the way down from Hollywood to try
your guys's tacos and we're wondering if
we could just buy two and just eat them
outside over here okay do you want me to
meet you down by the gate here or at the
entrance oh okay we'll meet you at the
front gate okay thanks man I may have
three taco trucks worth of tacos in my
stomach but I am far from done sir okay
we can't film inside them that's fine
well see you guys later
[Music]
how different is this experience right
now this experience I would say
accessibility gotta be a one out of ten
that's not fair to tonsure that's
probably not fair to chancho selmour a
commentary on you sir alright let's eat
them great crunch to this taco okay it's
really good this is the McDonald's of
taco truck but that's not that's not
even like a dish that's not a diss at
all it's Americanized for sure but you
know what I'm not mad at it when we set
out to do this journey today we weren't
trying to find the most authentic taco
in LA we were trying to find the best
experience because we're a fan of tacos
of all shapes and sizes and this is a
great taco oh the carnitas is bumpin
what's your favorite part the shell the
meat I I think the shell not to keep
going back to my grandma's tacos this
isn't like my grandma's tacos cuz it's
clearly just a hard shell yeah and it
looks like these are you know homemade
shells not just you know you go to
Albertsons and you get like a 10 pack
you know it's interesting I've never had
pork inside a hard shell taco that's
true yeah when a taco field day soccer
training are we going up okay yeah how'd
you do it's like a stomach why
surprisingly my stomach is like still
ready to go what's up next big guy I
wish never calls me big guy yeah my
stomach is the only person that calls a
big guy we missed them we missed the
exit didn't we it's so hard to know
where to go there's a map in your head
on this three I'm not sure if it's left
or right what's this one called
Jorge's that's not it would it be rude
to ask another taco truck I think I see
now we're okay
yeah all right we're calling it well we
didn't find Jorge's tacos tonight but
but tomorrow we might find it right yeah
are we gonna cut to a Shutterstock
footage of the Sun going down and then
the Sun rising q Shutterstock footage of
sunset over Los Angeles oh yeah joining
us sunrise as well I think then the Sun
rises oh maybe a cafe like coffee oh you
people drinking coffee yeah yeah like on
the side of the street that's good
and then now after all of that is done
we will cut back to you driving in a new
outfit tomorrow quickly
I found out why we couldn't find Jorge
sockos last night and it's cuz they're
not open Wednesday's who's not open for
business on hump day maybe they go out
so hard on Taco Tuesday that they're
just like we need a break on Wednesday
man alright first place we're going to
is a walk scott on wheels
that can't be how you pronounce that by
the way is that how you pronounce it
yeah I think so
all right I'm gonna have to walk for
this one through a business some fight I
asked him we're getting a Washington
steak tacos that's a lot yes
all right great look there's a waterfall
over there with a seagull on top of it
[Music]
the meat is very savory its juicy the
meats the best part tortillas very
sudden part of them really I find a
torch here to be okay
a very juicy savory meat almost kind of
like a green barbecue meat sliced up you
know what I just dig tacos baby that's
what I'm here for
maybe it's that the tortillas so big
like this probably looks like a super
Wimpy taco you're so good work be
doggone okay it's still yeah it's still
taco it's still delicious all this trash
talk and yet he's chomping away would
you drive for these tacos though no but
if I saw them hell yeah I am I gonna
pony up and buy some and with that let's
head to the next one yeah we around a
budget a budget one a time budget yeah
we're at a time running out of daylight
we gotta go
finally enough the taco truck that we're
going to next is actually at the office
a little bit of a blender on our part we
thought we were gonna have to drive to
Santa Monica
turns out Kogi actually came to us coley
Katrine just fell down in front of us
that's la okay take two spicy pork tacos
and in two short rib tacos
[Music]
it's a fusion taco and it's basically
what I am half Mexican half asian look
at how cool this taco is it's a full
party in here and they're all having a
great time yeah hold on to your butt's
God
just a delight everything is just
spot-on perfect there's so much greenery
normally I don't really appreciate it
when someone puts an entire garden in my
burrito
definitely not my tacos here I would say
that the the veggies aren't even
sidekicks I'd say they're 1a and 1b with
the meat everyone is singing an equal
volume and it's a harmony that I enjoy
it's a little bit on the pricier side
but you are paying for a fusion
experience so I think Koji was one of
the first places to do the fusion of
Korean and Mexican together
well my parents did it a while ago Wow
gross stop - all right so we're headed
to Leo's taco truck on South La Brea
now Leo's taco truck is a well-known
name in the la taco community it's
somewhat of an institution you know
another white guy and Asian guy went to
this track the taco truck that works at
the soup oh is it the word that boys
that is so good it's so simple it's
perfect
well well a little Steven little some
fact taco fact let me give you my taco
dance that's how I Steven Lim impression
after we go there they're not gonna say
it's those words at boys that came here
they're gonna say Ryan and Brent on
their taco tour came here and uh we'll
have to make that into a sticker we'll
find a better name but it's kind of long
for a sticker we'll make it shorter well
we'll see you at the taco truck oh let's
cut to that now this is a fill time as a
stack taco its small its stout yeah but
it is it is very packed it's a dollar 25
okay okay it almost kind of shifts over
to the the spectrum of sausage like 20
so hmm
it's very tasty meat a lot of people
claim this is the best pass store in La
fronte even says the best tacos al
pastor don't know about that it might be
the best for the price for the perhaps
the flavor profiles winner a little
different than typical
yeah we get it you drive a motorcycle
everyone's frigging impressed yeah
anyways I keep going and it's mediocre
and then I remember the price holy cow
for a dollar 25 that's a damn good time
now alrighty next one is called
huitlacoche it's like some sort of
fungus corn thing whoo
hell yeah let's download some fungus
right into my body I want to have three
arms by the time this day is done two
orders of the lamb tacos and the tours
there's a quick hello Jeff
how do you how you say that that's good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this this is a lamb taco and this one
over here I believe is Mexican truffle
from what he said
interesting it's got a sweet flavor but
that's pretty much it there's not really
a spice it kind of tastes like grilled
onion on a tortilla that's kind of what
it tastes like actually I think that's
pretty accurate
what the hell this tastes like something
that you would put on top of another
taco reading condiments right now but
for me it needs a meat on my taco and
that's where I'm heading over to lamb
tone okay got it very good oh holy [ __ ]
that's succulent oh there's so much love
that went into this taco what's that
soft sleeper I'm not quite sure
Jesus is tears finger licking good
literally are we driving to this taco
track again I probably would it knows
it's an itch and it's it's nailing it
Tamar ghost Moss let's do it it's 7:30
now sunsets going down we have to we're
not even wearing a watch I don't know
why you did that
let's just have it okay and we're headed
to tacos own taco zone hold up they're
shooting a movie la baby city of the
stars
[Applause]
but oh there it is taco zone I see it
yeah yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's just what do our first reader down
otago to drive it just sucked all the
saliva out of my mouth like a desert now
this meat needs a glass of water yeah so
do I let's try the past door which is
the main singer for me whoa cinnamon oh
yeah oh this is no analog taco dance
baby taking me down a taco town yeah I
don't like it I love it out of my mouth
right now what's happening it tastes
like I made a gingerbread cookie in neat
form this is past door that's gone in a
whimsical adventure through the the
magic cherry forest and it's come out as
cinnamon my mind is blown that is the
weirdest tasting past where I've ever
had in my life I feel like I'm being
punked right now is there another
another camera crew is gonna pop out
behind this Prius right here all right
would you drive here again yeah I would
have to drive here to taste it again
because I've never tasted it like this
before you know I just realized it's not
tacos own it's tacos zone there's an S
at the end of tacos and beef tacos zone
you don't need to put the S there we
know there's plenty of tacos in the
tacos on it
oh I'm not I kind of trade it's going on
there it is Jorge's tacos but that was
easy
all right let's Park this bad boy and
finish this up
[Applause]
so we have a mesquite grill carne asada
that's what they're known for right the
skeet grill with carne asada mm-hmm and
then we also have the al pastor I'm
gonna go past door first oh that is
juicy heaven the pinto beans actually
make me feel like I'm eating a burrito I
would give it 7 out of 10 pinto beans
all right let's try this one to speak
grilled up as a asada Oh mm-hmm
I was about to say this tastes like
asado but then a second profile hit me
and it did taste very musky d holy [ __ ]
a bleep er Mesquite got this smoky
finish even almost like a spice to it
it's kind of making my tongue kind of
tingle I think that's why it has that
gourmet meaty finish because it feels
like something would be that would be
served in a restaurant except it's on a
tortilla yeah I'm different and I'm
eating in him in a parking lot it's a
hundred percent with you
all right we're late so we're gonna do
our final thoughts on our way as well on
our way back to the and Brent's gonna
ruin his pants
we're if we make it to the office alive
we will do fine oh that's the thing you
want to see be from the person that's
gonna be behind the wheel all right
let's go let's go this is the visit the
moment you've been waiting for the
winner of the top ten taco truck in LA
oh boy I haven't prepared anything my
mind is what mariscos Elise goes that's
the one that keeps coming back
Maurice cook Elise go what goddamn good
I'm picking it because I can't even
remember all the taco places we've been
to places don't want to stands out
exactly and that's the one that I am
craving again
yeah you know what I'm going marisco
Jalisco as well yeah yeah it's pretty
good yeah synergy I'll say that was
number one it was followed closely with
Kogi nipping at his heels and then after
that Ricky's fish tacos nipping at those
heels see they all have their own merits
you know I'm not here to say one is
better than the other or that you
shouldn't go to this one you should go
to that one try all of these joints out
they're all delicious I think what I
learned today is that uh it's in the
shape of a taco I'm probably gonna like
it for the most part I wouldn't
recommend doing all ten no in the way we
did it because I'm physically and
mentally exhausted right now there's
sweat coming out of places I didn't know
I could sweat from I'm sweating out of
my knees well that's that then that's
that I'm sure you have an out there
somewhere something taco related let's
cut the video out there we use the taco
related and roll credits right
[Music]
[Music]